What if I told you you don't need to
carry on home schooling your children.
"What?"
Not for English in any case, we know
that being at home has suddenly meant
that you've become professional cooks,
cleaners, teachers as well as continuing
with your day job.  We're taking your
child's English lessons online!
"Hi guys !" "Hi!". Virtual lessons are designed to provide the same progress as regular lessons in a fun and
productive manner. "I'm a stay at home student".
"That's great English".
There will be an element of interactive guided
learning before and after the class.
"I really liked exercise 2". This is to
make sure your child gets the most out
of their online English learning
experience. The virtual lessons platform
is easy to use and safe. So what will your
child need. They'll need a laptop with
audio and video features. They'll need to
be in a suitably quiet place
with minimal distraction.
boy screaming in background !
"How do  I mute?"
There's no way she's
gonna be learning English.  They'll also
need to have a good Wi-Fi connection
"Mummy I can't hear anything...!"
You really do not want to find yourself in
that situation.
The platform we use will
allow your child to participate in pair work.
"What's it like to live in Paris?"
"Well now, It's raining."
And group work.
That was very interesting"
"Shall we do it again?"
"It's a giraffe"
"It's' an elephant"
"It's called .."
Child protection is of the upmost important to us.
We have very strict anti-bullying policies.
Along with other housekeeping rules.
that you
can read about on our website.
Learning online will build your child's confidence,
their resilience, their digital skills
and their communication skills.
If you have any questions, please do not
hesitate to contact
your local British Council centre.
"Can you help with biology?"
Mmmm, we're sticking to English.
We look forward to seeing your child in an
online lesson.
Really soon!
"Bye".